[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض هذه ابرز عناوينها
مراكز الاقتراع للانتخابات التركيه تستعد
لاغلاق ابوابها وبدء عمليات فرز اصواتنا
الخارجيه الليبيه تعلن وصول وفد سعودي
لمطار معي لبحث اعاده فتح السفاره في
طرابلس
مع انتهاء التسجيل 252 كويتيا يترشحون
للانتخابات البرلمانيه بينهم خمسه عشره
تمره
في الرابع ايضا
الاعلان عن حي الملك سلمان في مدينه
الرياض بعد اعاده تطوير حيين سكنيين
وبعد فرضه رسوما على مرتديه امانه جده
تفتح احد الشواطئ مجانا وتتخذ اجراءات ضد
المستثمر
تستعد مراكز الاقتراع في تركيا الى اغلاق
ابوابها بعد نحو ساعه من الان لتبدا
عمليات الفرز للانتخابات الرئاسيه التي
يتنافس عليها ثلاثه مرشحين بينهم الرئيس
الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان كلام او كمال
كليتش دار اوغلو قال خلال ادلائه بصوته ان
الربيع قادم الى بلاده لما اتمنى اردوغان
وخلال الادلاء بصوته بان يتم فرز الاصوات
دون مشاكل
[موسيقى]
ويرزقك الله
اتابع العمليه الانتخابيه منذ ساعات
الصباح الاولى وابلغني وزير الداخليه ان
العمليه تسير بلا مشاكل كان من المهم ضمان
استمرار عمليه التصويت في المناطق
المنكوبه بالزلازل فهناك من سيدلون
باصواتهم بحماس كبير واتمنى ان تمر عمليه
الفرز مساء بلا مشاكل وادعو جميع
المواطنين للادلاء باصواتهم حتى الخامسه
عصرا لاظهار قوه ديمقراطيتنا واشكر وابارك
للجميع
لقد افتقدنا جميعا الديمقراطيه افتقدنا
لان نكون معا ونحتضن بعضنا البعض من اليوم
سيتغير وجه تركيا سياتي الربيع الى هذا
البلد اقدم لكل من جاء وادلى بصوته عميق
الحب والاحترام
عضو لجنه المركزيه العليا في حزب العداله
والتنميه في تركيا ان العمليات الانتخابيه
تمر بامان وانا وعي الشعب بالديمقراطيه
يضمن سير الانتخابات بلا اي عقبات
العمليه الانتخابيه تتم بسلام وهدوء
ونتوقع ان تتم هكذا حتى نهايه اليوم الوعي
الديمقراطي الكبير لدى شعبنا التركي سيدمن
سير العمليه بدون اي عقبات في تاريخ
الديمقراطيه التركيه لم يحدث ابدا اي
عاقبات كبيره او احداث امنيه استفزازيه
وهكذا سيكون الامر في العمليه الحاليه
تركيا دوله مؤسسيه ومؤسساتنا الامنيه على
اهبه الاستعداد لتامين عمليه الانتخابات
والتصدي لاي محاوله اختراق او تزوير او
اضطراب تجربتنا الديمقراطيه عريقه
كما اوضح احد المراقبين الاتراك ان توقيت
العمليه الانتخابيه هذا العام جاء بوقت
افضل من السابق مؤكدا اللا خروقاته او
خروقات سجلت حتى الان
نسبه التصويت في هذه الانتخابات مقارنه
بالانتخابات الماضيه افضل بكثير
الانتخابات الماضيه كانت تاتي وقت العطله
الصيفيه والاجازات لكن توقيت هذه
الانتخابات افضل الى الان لا توجد هناك اي
خروج في هذه المنطقه هناك هدوء جيد
والامور تسير على ما يرام حتى الان
المتابعه ينضم الينا من اسطنبول مفرد
العربيه الطاهر بركه من هاتاي عبد القادر
خربوش اهلا بكم اعداء معك طاهر الاجواء
الان والمشهد الان كيف يبدو قبل ساعه
تقريبا من اغلاق مراكز الاقتراع
اهلا خالد وبالمشاهدين طبعا اقل من ساعه
قبل اغلاق صناديق الاقتراع نحن انتقلنا
الى ثالث مدرسه وصلنا اليها اليوم في
اسطنبول ويمكن ان تشاهد من خلفي لاننا
منعنا من الدخول الى داخلها ولكن سمح لنا
بالوقوف في خارجها يمكن ان ناتي لكم
بالصوره باقرب ما يمكن لكثير من الحشود في
الواقع من الذين يتجمهرون في هذه المدرسه
ما هي هذه المدرسه التي اتينا اليها
ولماذا خالد هذه مدارس امام خطيب التي
يدرس فيها الائمه والخطباء في تركيا من
تخرج من هذه المدارس ولنكون دقيقين ليس من
هذا الفرع يعني لانها تملك فروعا عديده
ولكن من ثانويه امام خطيب الرئيس التركي
الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان درس في امام خطيب
وهناك من يقول يعني معلومات تتحدث عن انه
الثلث اعضاء حزب العداله والتنميه درسوا
هذه المدارس
ويمكن ان نلحظ يعني صبغه من هذا النوع على
طبيعه الامور هنا في هذه المدرسه مدرسه
امام خطيب التي جئنا اليها وفيها حشود
كبيره وفيها الناس يهرولون قبل انتهاء
ساعات الاقتراع يهرولون للادلاء بصوتهم
رغم اننا كنا اعتقدنا بانه العدد الاكبر
صوت في الفتره الاولى من النهار الا انه
لا تزال الاعداد تاتي الى هذا المركز
للادلاء باصواتهم هناك رغبه حقيقيه
بالتعبير عن ارائهم بغض النظر عن هذا
الانقسام الحاصل بين هذا المرشح او ذاك او
هذا التحالف او ذاك الا انه لا شك بانه
كما قيل لنا حتى من المسؤولين الاتراك
الذين تحدثنا عنهم رئيس بلديه اسكودار حيث
صوت الرئيس اردوغان اليوم وكذلك احد
المشرفين والمسؤولين الانتخابيين على هذا
المركز الذي نقف بجانبه قالوا ان النسب
الاقتراع يعني لا تقارن باكثر الانتخابات
السابقه حتى وان ساعات يعني سالته بناء
على ما يحصل احيانا في عدد من الدول
العربيه في الانتخابات احيانا تمدد ساعه
الاقتراع قال لا هذا هو القانون ولن نمدد
ساعات الاقتراع عند الساعه الخامسه سنقفل
صناديق وتاخذ العمليه مجراها الطبيعي
المعلن عنه فيما يتعلق بنقل الاصوات
بفرزها ونحن يعني استدراكا لذلك سننتقل
بعد قليل الى مقر حزب العداله
والتنميه في اسطنبول هو المقر الرئيس حيث
مررنا من جانبه قبل قليل وبدات بالفعل
التحضيرات على قدم وساق
لاحتواء مناصري حزب العداله والتنميه هناك
كما عدد من الاحزاب والتحالفات الاخرى
الذين يجهزون ايضا وعدد من الزملاء هناك
اصلا وستتحدثون اليهم بطبيعه الحال اي
اقصد ان تتحالف الامه او المعارضه
الكل بانتظار ساعه الحسم ساعه الصفر
لاعلان النتائج
التي ستكون بدون شك مفصليه بالنسبه الى
تركيا منها ايضا ينضم الينا عبد القادر
الخربوش وكذلك انضمت الينا الان زميل
فاطمه فهد منفردات العربيه الى انقره
هاتين ماذا تقول الان او لمن ستصوت وهي
المدينه المنكوبه من الزلزال هذا الملف
الذي سيؤثر بكل تاكيد على حضور وفرص
المرشحين في هذه الانتخابات
نعم خالد صوت تتر رغم انها مكلومه صوتتها
صوت رغم انها خاليه من سكانها عادوا اليها
من
الولايات التي يعني نزحوا اليها عادوا
اليها بقوه هذا ما كان مفاجئا منذ ساعات
الاولى لصباح اليوم شاهدنا يعني اقبال
كبير على مراكز الاقتراع وسط الدمار هذه
المراكز التي قاومت الردات او هزات
الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه
فقدموا وانتخبوا وادلوا باصواتهم وقالوا
كلمتهم في هذا الاستحقاق الرئاسي الهام
جدا قبل ساعه من اغلاق مكاتب الاقتراع خفت
الحركه بالمراكز ويبدو ان الاعداد قلت
بشكل يعني ملحوظ جدا صرنا يعني نعود
الوافدين بالناخب
بالواحد ولا اثنين يعني فهذا يدل على ان
ساعه حسم النتائج يعني لم تعد طويله وبعد
الساعه الخامسه سيتم غلق مكاتب الاقتراع
لتبدا عمليه فرز الاصوات ومع ذلك يصل بين
الفينه والاخرى البعض للمشاركه والادلاء
باصواتهم نذكر فقط ان من يشاركون في هذه
الانتخابات ياتون من مناطق بعيده بالاضافه
الى من هم يعيشون في الخيام والبيوت
الجاهزه ومختلف المخيمات المنتشره في محيط
هذه الولايه المنكوبه لمن يصوتون ولمن
ترجح الكفه لاحد يمكن ان يعلم النتيجه لحد
الان رغم ان نحن نشارف على بدء عمليه
الفرز الا ان الاراء كانت متباينه
ومتقاربه على الاقل هنا في المناطق
المتضرره من الزلزال على عكس التوقعات
التي كانت سابقا كان هناك استغلال كبير
سياسيا لازمه الزلزال بالتحديد من قبل
المعارضه لانتقاد الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
وحكومته في طريقه ادارتهم للازمه وما
وصفوه بالتقصير اتجاه المتضررين والوصول
متاخرين بالخصوص خلال الايام الثلاثه
الاولى لكن راينا ايضا مؤيدين وقالوا بان
الحكومه لم تدخر جهدا حتى وان تاخرت خلال
الايام الثلاثه الاولى الا انها عادت
واستدركت وان الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان قدم
كل ما استطاع تقديمه من مساعده للمتضررين
وايضا قدم وعودا بمشاريع ضخمه لاعاده
اعمار هذه المناطق
المتضرره وتعويض كل المتضررين بالسكنات
بالتحديد لذلك لا لا لم يبدوا اي مخاطره
وفق ما ذكروا لنا بان يتخلوا عن الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان لاكمال ما لهم به في حين
ان معارضي
اردوغان يرون بانه فشل على الاقل في اداره
هذه الازمه هنا بمناطق الزلزال ولو ان
الرقم الانتخابي ونسبه الاعداد الناخبين
في مناطق الزلزال ليست بالكبيره جدا
مقارنه مع العدد الاجمالي اكثر من 60
مليون ناخب من يعيشون في مناطق الزلزال لا
يتعدى عددهم تسعه ملايين ناخب مسجل اي ما
نسبته حوالي 14 في المئه ولكن تاثيرهم
سيكون كبير جدا بالتاكيد بالخصوص مع
الارتدادات السياسيه التي لحقت الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان في المدن الكبرى
والموجه الجديده من الجيل الجديد الذي
سينتخب لاول مره ويقدر عدد ناخبي وهم
الشباب باكثر من اربعه ملايين ناخب خالد
فاطمه ماذا تقول عن قرر
الان خالد يعني بدات تخف او يخف الازدحام
على مراكز الاقتراع مع قرب اغلاق ابواب
الاقتراع على تمام الساعه الخامسه مساء
يعني دخلنا قبل قليل الى اللجان المشرفه
على عمليه الاقتراع وقالوا بان نسبه
التصويت وصلت في هذا المركز تحديدا ما بين
85 الى 95% من الناخبين وصلوا وادلب
باصواتهم طبعا تمام الساعه الخامسه تغلق
تغلق الابواب ولكن يبدا اللجان من الداخل
والعاملين في مراكز الاقتراع بالادلاء
باصواتهم بعد ذلك يقومون بفرز الاصوات
وسنتابع طبعا هذه العمليه معكم تباعا الى
ان نصل تمام الساعه 9:00 مساء والتي
المفترض ان ينتهي فيها الصمت الانتخابي
وفي تمام ربما الساعه 11 يبدا اعلان
النتائج والكثير من المحللين يقولون بانه
ربما ستحسن من الجوله الاولى خصوصا بعد
خروج محرم انجي وتوجه جميع الانظار لصالح
اردوغان او الاصوات لصالح اردوغان ويعني
ما ان نظرنا الى السوشيال ميديا خالد والى
التغريدات وتعليقات الناس يبدو ان هناك
خروقات غير مؤكده للصمت الانتخابي هناك
خروقات واتهامات من المعارضه للحزب الحاكم
بتزوير وبمحاوله التلاعب في الانتخابات
وفي المقابل قبل يومين راينا حزبه التنميه
والعداله ايضا يتهم المعارضه بمحاوله
التلاعب في الانتخابات وتزوير كروت
انتخابات منذ ذلك الحين لاستخدامها
فالانتخابات اذا اتهامات ما زالت مستمره
بين الجانبين ولكن يبدو ان
يعني القرار المفصلي سيكون في الساعات
الاخيره من هذا المساء
طاهر من خلال يعني متابعتك الان ونحن امام
ربما اخر ساعه قد تكون حاسمه في توجه
الناخبين لمستقبل تركيا في انتخاباتها
الاكثر تعقيدا هي الاكثر حساسيه واهميه
ربما يتغير شكل تركيا وشكل المنطقه ايضا
في حال فوز المعارضه تحديدا بعد عقدين
حكما فيها اردوغان الكلمه الحاسمه في هذه
الانتخابات هل ستكون لاسطنبول باعتبارها
للخزان
للانتخابات والاصوات ام لناخبين الجدد من
الشباب ومن النساء ام لهذه المدن المنكوبه
التي تاثرت من الزلزال برايك سريعا
خالد هناك يعني كل هذه العوامل يمكن جمعها
في بوتقه واحده لكي تعطينا صوره عن هذه
المعادله التي تريد ان تصل اليها اسطنبول
طبعا نتحدث عن احد عشر مليون ناخب من اصل
اكثر من خمسه عشر مليون يعني قاتل في
اسطنبول او تركي في اسطنبول اضافه الى
يعني اعداد اخرى يمكن ان اتحدث عنها عن
الناخبين الشباب الذين ذكرتهم فيما يتعلق
باكثر من خمسه ملايين يصوتون للمره الاولى
هؤلاء يعني عناصر مهمه جدا ولكن كلهم
مجتمعون بدون شك سيعطون ويفرزون النتيجه
النهائيه سواء انتهت من الجوله الاولى
للرئاسيات او اضطر تره التركي الى
الانتقال الى جوله ثانيه في هذه الرئاسيات
وهنا نقطه مهمه من يفوز في البرلمان قد
يؤثر كثيرا في الاسبوعين المقبلين ريثما
تاتي جوله الاعاده في الثامن والعشرين من
مايو عدد كبير من العوامل يلعب دور لا
يمكن القول بانه اسطنبول لوحدها تقرر نحن
نتحدث عن 11 مليون ناخب ولكن من اكثر من
يعني نحو 64 مليونا واذا كانت نسبه
الاقتراع تصل الى 90% اذا نتحدث عن 58
مليون ان يقتنعون في اسطنبول 11 مليون هي
الاولى هي خزان بشري هي جامعه شامله
لمختلف الاطياف والشرائح نعم ولكن يعني لا
يمكن ان نحسب انها الاكثر يعني هي من
الاكثر تاثيرا ولكنها لكننا لا يمكن ان
نحسب انها الوحيده هناك مناطق اخرى مهمه
جدا ايضا وعوامل اخرى تؤثر على كل تركيا
وليس فقط على اسطنبول فيما يتعلق بعنصر
الشباب عنصر الاقتصاد موضوع اللاجئين
موضوع العلاقه مع الغرب العلاقه مع روسيا
الى ما هنالك من كل الاتهامات القاسيه
التي كان يسوقها كل طرف للطرف الاخر في
هذه الحملات الانتخابيه ولكن هذا يوم
انتخابي بدون شك مره بكل هدوء وكل
التصريحات تقول فيما يتعلق سؤالك عن اذا
فازت المعارضه واذا فازت الموالاه دائما
ما كنا نسال اذا كان سيحصل اعمال عنف يبدو
ان المعلومات يعني الكل مرتاحون الى انه
يعني لا لن تحصل احداث عنف الا اذا اتضح
غير ذلك في الساعات المقبله اذا كان في
هناك يعني اتهامات بالتزوير او طعون او
الى ما هنالك ولكن مبدئيا الكل يقول انه
حتى من مسؤوليه حزب العداله والتنميه حتى
الرئيس نفسه حتى مسؤوليه حتى مسؤوليه
بلديات وكلهم يقولون سنسلم السلطه لانه
هذا يوم الديمقراطيه هو يوم الرابع عشر من
مايو نحن جئنا بالديمقراطيه وسنسلم
بالديمقراطيه هذا خطابهم لنرى
جزيلا لكم طاهر بركه من اسطنبول خربوش من
اتاي فاطمه فهد من انقره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الى الكويت حيث اغلق باب الترشيح
الانتخابات مجلس الامه 2023 بعد التسجيل
252 مرشحا من بينهم خمسه عشره كويتيه
وشاهد اليوم الاخير من التقدم او من
التقديم تقدم او 41 مرشحا ومرشحه بطلبات
ترشحهم
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الليبيه وصول وفد من
الخارجيه السعوديه الى مطار ماتيجا الدولي
في العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس واوضحت
الخارجيه الليبيه ان الهدف من الزياره هو
اعداد الترتيبات اللازمه لاعاده فتح
السفاره السعوديه
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل
مسوده جديده لحقوق المسافرين في السعوديه
تشدد على اعلان الرسوم وتعويض تاخير
الرحله
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنا ولي العهد السعودي
بمسماه الجديد ورفع معدلات الجوده
والخدمات الاساسيه والانشطه الترفيهيه
والترويحيه وتطويره وخلقي هويه ايضا
عمرانيه ومعماريه للمرافق العامه في الحي
منبثقه من العماره السلمانيه ومبادئها
معنى عبر الهاتف امين منطقه الرياض الامير
فيصل بن عياف اسمه الامير حياك الله معي
مبروك اولا اطلاق هذا المشروع حي الملك
سلمان لكن بودي يعني اسالك اولا عن الفكره
من الدمج دمج الحيين
معروفين في الرياض وايضا اعاده التسميه
احب اتوجه بالشكر الجزيل سمو سيدي ولي
العهد الله يحفظك
لتسميه الحي باسم حي الملك سلمان حقيقه
سبب التسميه هو عرفان الملك مولاي الملك
الله يحفظه
على خمسه عقود قضاها الملك ايام عمارته
لمنطقه الرياض
يعد الملك الله يحفظه باني الرياض الحديثه
مهندس نهضتها في عهده طبعا انتقلت المدينه
لتصبح المدينه اللي يشوفها اليوم مدينه
عالميه تنافس المدن الكبرى بنيت المشاريع
وخططت المدينه
ونفدت كثير منها الحمد لله والبنيه
التحتيه اللي نعيش فيها اليوم هي نتيجه
لتخطيط وعمل كبير الفتره فسبب التسميه هو
عرفان للملك الله يحفظه عرسان ذيك الفتره
عرفان للعمل والانجازات ما الذي سيميز هذا
الحيل
حقيقه متفائلين ان شاء الله طبعا الحي
الان في عدد كبير من المزايا التي سيبنى
عليها باذن الله اول ما ميز الحي اليوم
حقيقه موقع المهم جدا الحي في قلب مدينه
الرياض يطل على حديقه الملك سلمان اللي
تحت الانشاء باذن الله واللي تعتبر اكبر
حديقه
حضريه على مستوى العالم فاطلاقنا الحديقه
لن تكون اطاله شكليه فقط بل باذن الله
سيتكامل الحي معها من خلال ربط المباشر في
المناطق الخضراء الممتده وكذلك مسارات
الدراجات وغيرها كذلك مميز الحي بشكل كبير
وسيميز اثناء تطوير ان شاء الله تطبيق عدد
كبير من مفاهيم الانسنه بحيث يكون الحي
يعني جوده الحياه في مرتفعه باذن الله
يميز الحي اليوم بنيه تحتيه جيده جدا
نطمح ان شاء الله اثناء عمليه التطوير
لتحسينها وتطويرها زياده اللي تكون متكام
واخيرا ان شاء الله خلق هويه وتراجع
العمراني واضح للمنطقه
بعد ذلك من الاثر المتوقع من تطوير هذا
الحي بشكل عام
والله اخوي العزيز اعتقد الاثار المتوقعه
ان شاء الله كبيره لكن لو حاولت اني
اختصرها اعتقد ممكن يختصرها في خمسه نقاط
اساسيه
اعتقد النقطه الاولى التي ستكون يعني ان
شاء الله امامنا في الحي هي جوده الحياه
المرتفعه باذن الله مشاريع الانسه لا يخفى
عليك وعلى الساده المشاهدين لها تاثير
ايجابي جدا على جوده الحياه
وبنشر وباذن الله الانسن الكامله لمرافق
الحي
النقطه الاخرى اعتقد تكامل المشروع مع
المشاريع المحيطه باذن الله
سيكون سبب يعني
اساسيات
تكلمت قبل قليل عن حديقه الملك سلمان
والتكامل معها لكن ليس ذلك فقط
تكامل ان شاء الله مع مشروع المترو مع
الجامعات الموجوده جامعه الامير سلطان
وغيرها ما عدا كبير من المشاريع اللي
موجوده في الحي نعم تفضل لذلك
عن البنيه التحتيه وتطويرها اعتقد الاثر
المتوقع سيشمل ان شاء الله صوره التنقل
داخل الحي للسكان ومن والى الحي وسيشمل
كافه وسائل النقل من سيارات من مشاهد من
دراجات باذن الله الاثر المتوقع كبير ان
شاء الله على الفراغات العامه وذلك يشمل
الشوارع لكن يشمل كذلك الحدائق والساحات
والميادين وغيرها من الاعمال واخيرا ان
شاء الله نطمح ان الحي يكون مثال ونموذج
يحتذى به الهويه العمرانيه نطم احنا ان
شاء الله كافه الفراغات العامه سيكون لها
طابع سلماني وتراجع العمراني سلماني اللي
اسس لها الملك الله يحفظ ايام اماره
الرياض في كثير من المشارير واللي يدمج
بين تراث المدينه وتاريخها
بالواقع وبالمستقبل كذلك الخطط التنفيذيه
والاليات لتنفيذ هذا المشروع بهذه الصوره
التي ذكرتها سمو الامير
بالتاكيد ان شاء الله المشروع يعني اليوم
تم الاعلان عن التسميه وبدايه العمل قريبا
ان شاء الله وباذن الله نرى النتائج في
الاشهر القادمه وسنوات القادمه باذن الله
اشكرك شكر جزيل الامير فيصل بن عياف امين
منطقه الرياض
طرحت منصه استطلاع مسوده جديده للائحه
حمايه حقوق المسافرين من 29 ماده تبين من
خلالها التزامات المسافر والناقل الجوي
والاعلانات واسعار تذاكر الطيران ياتي من
ابرزها مبدا الشفافيه الذي يلزم الناقل
الجوي بايضاح المعلومات اللازمه المتعلقه
باتمام عمليه الحجز وفقا لعقد النقل الجوي
المعلومات المتعلقه ايضا باليه معالجه
تاخير الرحلات او الغائها او رفض الاركاب
او تاخر الامتعه او تلفها بالاضافه الى
الاعلان عن مكونات سعر التذكره بشكل واضح
وغير مضلل
جديد او من جده عفوا ينضم الينا المعتز بن
حسن امير الخبير في اداره وتشغيل المطارات
حياك الله يا معتز
خالد حياك الله واشكرك على الاستضافه مش
الجديد
والتي جاءت بفضل الله ثم توجيهات القياده
الرشيده حفظه الله ومتابعه معالي وزير
النقل والخدمات اللوجستيه مع الرئيس
الهيئه وحرص جميع الجهات ذات العلاقه على
نجاح موسم العمره وخدمته الرحمن اما على
سؤالك الله يبارك فيك خلينا بس نقصل
لمساله معينه استاذ خالد انه هذه اللوائح
الخاصه بحمايه حقوق المسافرين موجوده نشاه
الطيران وذلك عبر التشريحات التشريعات
واللوائح الدوليه سواء او اياته وفق
معايير دوليه ابرزها اتفاقه اتفاقيه طبعا
لا يخفى عليك استاذ خالد ولا على سمع
الساده المشاهدين انه تحديث اللائحه بحقوق
المسافرين الخاصه بالمملكه العربيه
السعوديه كان اخر تحديث لها 2017 ميلاديه
لكن مع النهضه الشامله في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وفقت لرؤيه الملهم
وخاصه قصبه ذكر الاستراتيجي الوطني لقطاع
النقل للطيران المدني التوسع
والاستراتيجيه ما تطمح له من 330 مليون
مسافر و250
مهم جدا انه الناس تعرف انه التحديث
اللائحه ما جاء كذا اعتباطن ترى هذا عمل
يعني تم على مدى خمس سنوات وكان اهم عيار
لها انها تكون
معتمده فيها على تجربه المسافر خلينا
نتكلم على ابرز التغييرتين تمت لا يحاول
لابد ان ننوه على نقطه اهم انه هذه
التعديلات تعتبر مسوده الان وليست نهائيه
وهي تم نشرها على زي ما تفضلت على منصه
استقطاع باخذ اراء المستهلكين المستفيدين
وتنتهي بتاريخ 23/5 ومن ثم يتم عرضه على
مدى اداره الهيئه للاعمال ابرز الملامح
انا ارخصها في اربع نقاط للناحين اللي
تلامس حاجه المستهلكه والمسافر انه في
اضافه لماده تعالج تقديم اوقات الرحلات
لتكون وفق يبسطنا بسرعه معتز ما عندنا وقت
احنا طويل الموضوع
كان عندنا سابقا في اللائحه السابقه بس
ماده تعالج تاخير الرحلات تمام لكن الان
استحدثوا ماده تعالج تقديم اوقات الرحلات
يعني في بعض الاحيان يجيك راكب يتفاجئ انه
حجم الساعه اربعه يلاقي الرحله تقدمت
للساعه ثلاثه ففي ماده الان تم اضافتها في
هذا الموضوع
تعالجها وفق المواد كيف تعالجها
اوكي في خلينا نقول على موضوع تاخير
الرحلات لان هي تنطبق على الاثنين هي اللي
عندك مشكله الدائمه المستمره في كل خطوط
الطيران
سابقا كانت تاخير من ثلاثه الى سته ساعات
بقيمه 20 وحده وحده حقوق سحب طبعا يسال عن
وحده حقوق صعب السحب هي معيار نقدي
اللي هي وحده بديله للعملات
سابقه كان ما يتعدل 20 وحده حقوق سحب بما
يعادل تقريبا 100 ريال الان في حاله
التاخير من ثلاثه الى ست ساعات يحسب بقيمه
خمسين وحده سحب بما يعادل 260 ريال تقريبا
هذه من ثلاثه الى ست ساعات في حاله تاخر
الرحله من سته ساعات واكثر يتم
التعويض بقيمه 150 وحده حقوق سحب بما
يعادل 860 ريال اضافه لما كان سابقا اللي
هو من تقديم الرعايه من مرتبات ووجبات
وسكن فندقي هذه موجود زي ما هي لكن
بالاضافه لذلك الان في تعويضات ماديه بما
يخص التاخير بثلاثه ست ساعات لما ذكرنا
260 ريال او من سته ساعات واكثر بقيمه 860
ريال هذه نفسها في حاله تاخير تطبق ايضا
في حال تقديم اوقات الرحلات عن طريقه
اذا كانت يعني خلاف ما هو موجود في الحجز
في ماده ثانيه في اول كان في ماده صحيح
كانت في حمايه حقوق المسافرين انه لا يجب
على الناقل الجوي
التاخر على المدرج الان في ماده محطوطه
انه
ماده تعالج حاله تاخير يعني جلست ساعه
واكثر الان في المدرج بدون ما تقلع
الطائره شلون سريعه عادي برضو الان تعوض
زي ما تعوض في موضوع الغاء الرحلات على
نحو التالي خليني اعطيك هذا الموضوع عندنا
تعويض الغائب رحلات على نحو التالي اول
كان
واحد وكان موحد لكن الان الغاء الرحلات
صار عندك من 60 يوم الى 14 يوم يحقق
استرداد قيمه التذكره بالاضافه الى تعويض
خمسين في المئه الان ايضا من 14 يوم الى
24 ساعه يحق استرداد التذكره بالاضافه
لتعويض 75% من قيمه التذكره اقل من 24
ساعه يحقق استيراد قيمه التذكره بالاضافه
لتعويض 150% قيمه ومن اللي بيضمن تنفيذ
هذا
سابقه لكن ما تنفذ مين اللي بيضمن الحين
هذه اللائحه اذا صارت
انا اعطيك اخوي خالد اول شيء نحن متفائلين
خاصه لما ذكرتها
بتفاؤل التشاؤم يعني ممتاز
وابغى جهه منفذه او ضامنه انه تنفذ هذه
اللوائح احنا ما نحتاج اللوائح اعتقد احنا
نحتاج جهه تراقب وبالتالي تعطيه حق تعطي
الحق لشركه او تعطي الحق كذلك للمستفيد
فانا هذا اللي احتاجه الان انه هذه
اللوائح تنفذ وتضمن للجهه ان اصل الى
حقوقي فيها
زي ما قلت لك الضامن بعد الله سبحانه
وتعالى هي اللي هي العامه المدني ولولا
اهتمام بهذا الموضوع لما ابرز والهيئه مو
كانت هي الضامن سابقا صحيح لكن زي ما قلت
لك الان خلينا نقول لك نقطه متعلق بهذا
الموضوع عشان اثبت لك انه الهيئه الان في
طور التغيير اول كانت دور الهيئه مختلط ما
بين التشغيل
والتشريع لكن في الوقت الحالي من واحد
واحد عام 23 انفصلت الهيئه عن اي دور
تشغيلي في اي مطار مطارات المملكه وصار
دوره تشغيل معتمد على الشركات سواء شركه
مطارات جده او شركه مطارات القابضه او
شركه تجمع الثاني او ما الى ذلك لكن الان
صار دورها تنظيمي تشغيل فقط وهذه نقطه
مركز
ابدا ابدا يجب تقديم سكن فندقي ومواصلات
منه الى المطار لكل مسافر اذا تجاوزت مده
ست ساعات اول كان ثلاث ساعات ولا لا كان
وفقا اللائحه من ثلاثه لسته ساعات كان
مجرد
في المطار ست ساعات وبعدين بيفكروا
ينقلوني الى فندقها وبيوصلوني الى فندق مش
معقول
اكيد بس النقطه يا اخوي خالد انا حقيقه
شوف انا انسان الان زي ما اقول محايد انا
لا اله ولا وتكلم بصفتي كمختص في هذا
المجال لما انت تشوف انه في اضافه
لموضوع السكن والتقديم الرعايه والفندق
الى ذلك انه صار الان في زي الغرامه لما
يكون في عندك خمسين وحده
حقوقك صح في من ثلاثه الى سته ساعات بقيمه
260 ريال وبعدها يتم حساب 150 بقيمه 860
ريال يعني اطلع المسافر او المستهلك
بالاضافه الى الرعايه والمرطبات والوجبات
والسكن يطلع ايضا عن كل يوم مبلغ مالي ب
60 ريال لا حقيقه
لما ندخل في التفاصيل لهذه الامور تلاقي
انه في نقله نوعيه صريحه على مجال
الاستراتيجي على مجال للتطبيقي وعلامه
حقيقه يعني لا يعني لا نكون متشائمين ولا
نكون متفائلين زياده على اللزوم وانما
الحين على كل حال
المشاهدين كمان نستبشروا خير على موضوع
الامتعه وهو موضوع الامتعه شيء كبير الان
هل تعلمت شنطه فتعادل 180 148 وحده سحب
بمعدل 80800 ريال في اليوم الاول اليوم
الثاني 60 وحده يعني تزيد
لعلمك ترى تعرف انه اتفاقيه مونتريال لا
تتعدى 1200 لكن المملكه العربيه السعوديه
وفق الاستراتيجي وفقا
اللائحه الجديده تعوض باكثر من ذلك
يلا شكرا جزيلا لكم الله شركات الطيران
بعد هذه اللائحه
بلا هذه المشاكل
ميرا مجد
الغت محافظه جده عقد الاستثمار الخاص
بشاطئ ابحر الجنوبيه وفتحه للعام اوضحت
الامانه ان قرار الغاء عقد استثمار الشاطئ
جاء بعد رصد مخالفات على المستثمر لعدم
التزامه ببنود العقد التي تنص على فتح
الشاطئ للعام دون رسوم مؤكده ان اتخذت
الاجراءات النظاميه بحقه تمهيدا لفتحه
للعامه
الجنوبيه بجده ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
سلطان السلمي سلطان حياك الله ما هي قصه
هذا الشاطئ
اهلا بك خالد واهلا بكافه مشاهدي نشره
الرابعه نقف الان امام شاطئ واجهه ابحر
الجنوبيه هذه المنطقه التي ارتبطت في ذكرى
او بذكريات اهالي جده وزوار مدينه جده
نتحدث عن شاطئ يصل عمر الاكثر من خمسين
عام كانوا اهالي جده وزوار جده يعني
يستمتعون باوقاتهم وقضاء اوقات جميله
وسعيده هنا في هذه الشاطئ بعد ان تم
تطويره من قبل مستثمر من قبل شركه
السعوديه بعقد يصل الى مده سبعه سنوات
بحسب المصادر نتحدث انه مساحه تصل الى
تسعه عشر الفا متر مربع مساحه هذه الواجهه
التي تم تطويرها من قبل المستثمر نتحدث
انه توقف هذا المشروع لقرابه ثلاثه سنوات
ولا عاد قبل فتره من الزمن اشهر محدوده
الى تشغيل هذه الشاطئ وفتحي من جديد
للزوار ولكن قامت امانه محافظه جده بالغاء
باغلاق هذه الواجهه البحريه وكذلك الغاء
العقد مع المستثمر بعد ان خالف اهم بنود
العقد وهي ان يفتح هذا الشاطئ او هذه
الواجهه البحريه للزوار والسياح والمقيمين
بجده بشكل مجاني تم فرض رسوم من قبل
مستثمر تصل الى خمسه وستين ريال للشخص
الواحد ايضا نتحدث انه تم
مخالفه او تم
او تم عدد من المخالفات ابرزها هي تصوير
هذا هذه الواجهه البحريه وكذلك اخذ رسوم
بقيمه تصل الى 65 ريال وكذلك نتحدث ايضا
عن مخالفات ماليه بعدم التزام المستثمر
بتسديد امانه جده كمستحقات ماليه متاخر
لذلك قامت محافظه جده باغلاق هذه الواجهه
البحريه يتصل مساحتها الى تسعه عشره الفا
متر مربع اثناء تواجدنا خلال الساعتين
الماضيه هنا في الواجهه البحريه كثير من
السياح وكثير من المواطنين المقيمين الذين
اتوا بعائلتهم وتفاجئوا بعمليه الاغلاق
وكانوا قد زاروا هذه المنطقه واستمتعوا
وكانت هنالك ردود فعل مختلفه مؤيد وبين
معارض لهذه لهذا الاقفال هناك من تحدث انه
المفترض ان تكون بعدم لا تكون هنالك رسوم
ماليه على الدخول نظرا ان هنالك اوامر
ساميه بفتح الشواطئ ايضا تكون المبالغ
الماليه محدوده جدا وفي متناول الجميع
هنالك عائلات بعدد كبير من الاطفال وغيرهم
يرغبون بالاستمتاع في اجواء جده خصوصا مع
دخول فتره الصيف هنالك فرصه كبيره
للاستمتاع بهذه الواجهه بعد ان تم العمل
عليها واعاده تشغيلها بشكل يتناسب مع
السياحه ومع الاهالي وهنالك طالبت بشكل
واضح يتم الغاء هذا العقد وان يكون هنالك
مستثمر اخر امانه جدا بلغتنا انه الان تم
اغلاقه وعمليه فتحه تحت الاجرام المتوقع
في الفتره الحاليه ان يتم تشغيله من قبل
امانه جده حتى ان يكون هنالك مستثمر اخر
يقوم باستلام الموقع واعاده تشغيله
والتاكيد على عمليه دفع عدم دفع رسوم
ماليه على الزواره والسياح الراغبين
بالقدوم الى واجهه ابحر الجنوبيه
الاستمتاع بهذه المنطقه من الداخله طلام
مغلق لا نستطيع الدخول الى الداخل لرصد
داخل هذه الواجهه لكن هنالك جلسات كراسي
للسباحه وجلسات ومظلات شمسيه بالضبط هنالك
مطاعم وكافيهات وايضا جلسات وكراسي ومظلات
شمسيه ودوره مياه وغيرها من الخدمات يعني
الكثير من اهالي جدا الحقيقه خالد
استفادوا من هذا الموقع او من هذه الواجهه
بعد ان تم التعديل عليها واعاده تشغيلها
بشكل جيد ولكن هنالك اراء اخرى تطالب ان
يلغى هذا العقد وان يكون بشكل مجاني بحسب
الاوامر الساميه قد يرى البعض انه مبلغ 65
ريال ومبلغ كبير لسيما انه قد ياتي البعض
برفقه اطفاله وعائلته يكون عددهم اربعه
الى خمسه اشخاص يرون هذا المبلغ كبير من
هنالك مشتريات اخرى داخل
هذه الواجهه من كمشروباتها وماكولات خفيفه
شكرا لك مراسل العربيه من شاطئ ابحر
الجنوبيه في جده
ايضا في الرابعه بعد الفاصل
وزاره البيئه السعوديه تعلنه عن اكبر طاقه
تخزينيه للحبوب في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد كشفت وزاره البيئه
والمياه والزراعه النجاح الهيئه العامه
للامن الغذائي في بناء اكبر طاقه تخزينيه
للحبوب في الشرق الاوسط بثلاثه ملايين
ونصف المليون طن بنسبه زياده بلغت 40% منذ
عام 2016
[موسيقى]
يتقارب طول الليل مع النهار في البلدان
العربيه عكس الدول الاوروبيه التي تكون
الغلبه لنهار صيفا والليل شتان خالد
[موسيقى]
تنطلق الشمس في رحله سنويه من الشمال الى
الجنوب على شكل بندول فوصولها الى اقصى
ميل لها شمالا دخول الصيف الفلكي ب22
يونيو ووصولها الى ادنى ميل لها جنوبا
دخول الشتاء الفلكي ب22 ديسمبر ومرورها
على خط الاستواء مرحله الاعتدال الربيعي
والخريفي ب22 مارس و22 سبتمبر والشمس تمر
على اجزائم من اليمن وسلطنه عمان
والسعوديه والامارات وهي طالعه فوق وتمر
عليهم مره ثانيه وهي نازله تحت فهذه
المناطق هي مناطق عبور في رحله الشمس
السنويه في رحله العمر والايام مسرعه لا
تنسى من انت او ما وجهت
السفر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وبما ان الشمس خلال هذه الفتره تتعامد على
المسطحات المائيه في بحر العرب وعلى ادائم
من اليمن وسلطنه عمان والسعوديه والامارات
فان مناخاتها خلال هذه الفتره تتسم بسرعه
التغيرات بسبب التباين الحاصل بين درجتي
الحراره العظمى والصغرى والفوارق الضغطيه
ولا تستقر اجوائها الا بعدما تنصرف الشمس
والعامه يقولون لا حر الا بعد الانصراف
وحين ذاك يبدا هبوب الرياح الصيفيه
المسماه برياح السموم هبت رياح الصيف
وتغير الجو وانا وليه في ميداني سمومه يا
شمس غيبي واختفي من ورا نوم لا تشرقي يا
شمس كوني
رحومه
[موسيقى]
العناوين
مراكز الاقتراع للانتخابات التركيه تستعد
لاغلاق ابوابها وبدء عمليه تفرزي
في الخارجيه الليبيه تعلن وصولها
مع انتهاء التسجيل 252 كويتيا يترشحون
للانتخابات البرلمانيه بينهم خمسه عشره
تمره
الاعلان عن حي الملك سلمان في مدينه
الرياض بعد اعاده تطوير حيين سكنيين حريين
بعد فرضه رسوما على مرتديا امانه جده تفتح
احد الشواطئ مجانا وتتخذ اجراءات ضد المست
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات